so
i have a preach
what are your views
on the current dating market and
do you join into the current market are
you out of it
okay i want to say two things
i'll be watching these videos on youtube
and i'm like where y'all meet these
women you feel what i'm saying i'm not
even frustrated it's not even like a
disrespectful it's like some of these
people that be coming on the lives and
stuff like that
just from my personal experience when i
was dating in los angeles or when i was
dating in in canada for me it wasn't
like that it wasn't that extreme but i
also filter out a lot of women who i'm
like this is a waste of time i could
just tell by the the pictures you choose
and what you like to promote instagram
that like
character is probably not your priority
you feel what i'm saying yeah like if i
go on a girl's ig page and there's a
bunch of strong pinks with a titty
popping out and her with like diamond
jewels we don't share the same value so
i'm not gonna miss it the same way if i
look at some guy and he was standing
beside jets and lambos and hoods up i'm
like that's not the kind of person i
want to hang with filter out folks based
off your values and how they present
themselves maybe their instagram is not
an indication of who they are and that's
fair but if you do really you go really
hard to portray something that tells me
something about you so there's some
times when i'm watching these videos and
i'm just like shorty's bugging but i
would have never figured it out because
i would have extra well before we even
get to the spot you know what i mean if
homegirl's waiting for me to pull up in
a tesla and take her somewhere she's
probably not the girl for me
even though i got the money for it yeah
it's not how i roll in because i'm like
you in it for the wrong reasons so i
don't even mess with people who move
different like that i don't lead with
the tesla i don't lead with all that
stuff that's not the way i do it so i
wouldn't even attract people who into
that people look at me like this man
look at you ain't got money good think
that yeah
because right now i'm coming with games
so either you in or you're not but if
you tell me it's because i got this car
that you in that we're not supposed to
be vibing because already i can already
tell your mindset isn't someone i want
to be around not even to say like i
wouldn't even want to smash yeah yeah
because like what does it mean when you
let somebody who's just having the money
inside your home around your private
possession do you know how many times
dudes take out like take back girls from
drunk hookups and get robbed afterwards
they get the quick little quaalude go to
sleep get their whole place robbed
understand how you attract these people
is oftentimes gonna lead to the outcomes
that you receive if you try to attract
women with cheese you're going to end up
with rats
that's a good part
bars
listen
listen i ain't mad bro
that was a good bar it's freak [ __ ] can
we just take a second let's take a
second even i like goddamn
is that yo
i don't think it is no it's too good to
be mine it's too good right no no i'm
not gonna fake that [ __ ] somebody google
it someone google that [ __ ] because
that's not my part that is not my part
yeah i must have heard it but it was
crazy what if it was i also wouldn't be
surprised
but i'm gonna be humbled enough to be no
i can't be my law i don't think i i
produce that
going to be humble enough google it it's
probably out there
if you did come up with it the lock's
about to call you i don't i don't
i don't think no i don't think no i
didn't no that's not my bar what do you
mean when someone like that gets hated
and angry and they're just after
material possession they don't have
character well that's when things go
south very fast you know the luxury i
have is like yo most of my dating
experiences are very positive because i
try to go for people who are not in it
for the wrong reasons you know i mean if
they want to smash they're there for the
right reasons if they want to hang out
or date desert for the right reasons so
for me i avoided a lot of negative stuff
because of the fact that i didn't go for
people who were into that let me you
know you got guys who get robbed you got
dudes getting fleece for all their money
and like how did that happen part of it
is also like who are the people you're
choosing you know if we come after women
and we say oh yeah this man left you for
this and that reason why did you pick
him we also have to look at men and say
well what were you advertising when you
tried to pull her in yeah do you feel
what i'm saying this is like the prime
mistake that dudes are like virgins or
sims or whatever make when they get
money is they think because you know you
give them advice like yo listen work on
yourself and confidence work on your
physique and things like that it doesn't
mean that once you get it all of a
sudden you're posing shirtless
everywhere it doesn't mean that once you
get the money all of a sudden you got
pictures that what these things do the
byproduct these things is they're
supposed to hand you some sense of
confidence you have these
accomplishments in life you can provide
certain things so symbolically they
matter right but it doesn't mean that
you lead with that because then it just
sounds like other than these things
anything else it's about how you get
there and the work that you have to put
in and what kind of character develops
you know when you get to be the ceo of
some company it's not like you're just
some virgin overnight and then you turn
into that there's a lot of hard work
that goes into that it's the byproduct
of that success
that drives a lot of people too that's
why there's some [ __ ] out there who
got no money but because they got the
game that comes from that experience
they can still pull what do you think
about what i said it was what it was you
said it all i mean there's nothing much
to add it's really that yeah and
especially if you're not about that life
you know that's what you advertise and
if you're about that life it's a
different thing it's a different thing
if you have all those positions good but
know what in
corny line
more money more problems it's actually
more money different problems if you
showcase it
it's not more problems
it's definitely different problems i'm
not gonna have the same problems as a
homeless person
but i'm gonna have the same problems of
someone with money and if i display it
like that there's money like that but i
can at least back it up
lawsuits all those big stars that i have
money like that money money money like
that don't display it but they do have a
special account for all those lawsuits
because people know they have money and
they don't even display it now imagine
if you have money and you display it
like that you put yourself in that
position you don't have the money you
fake that that you have all that money
but you put yourself in the position of
that
try to attract women with cheese
you know this is a matter of character
development and it's not even just about
talking to ladies this is about doing
difficult things in life in general for
me military wasn't for me but you know
what it was great for just developing as
a person that adversity shapes you
i was not used to that environment it
was very weird for me to have to wake up
at that time put on my uniform make sure
my kid is all perfect i have to rush
eating like i got habits and [ __ ] from
the military that i'm never going to let
go of it's just ingrained in me through
that experience and some would even say
trauma well you let go of the bed at 45
what the [ __ ] is this oh i'm done i'm
done you listen those whole 6 a.m runs
we do it for a bit i know and after i'm
like you think i'm waking up before the
sun [ __ ] that up
listen i know i know i did it in the
cadets eating fast
i can't stop yeah i can't
people like well how did you finish
someone said to me
oh abba i'm sorry because we were tired
we're having dinner oh i'm so sorry i
eat slow i'm like no [ __ ] i eat fast
it's a meat problem i know it's a meat
problem
i i look at my plan like where did my
food go do you understand how fast you
have to eat you know because you know
what it's like when you're sergeant
screaming at you six minutes six minutes
you rushing through the line to just get
what you can eat i used to stuff like
little snacks and [ __ ] like that in my
pockets and hide them you're not gonna
take it out of the mess
but you already know your boy was gonna
do it
yeah everyone was everywhere yeah yeah
yeah yeah if you look in enough members
pockets i guarantee you're gonna find
crumbs or something but
but all this to say all that experience
in life it makes you develop as a person
because like here's what happens right
you deal with something difficult a
difficult situation for example okay you
get your first paycheck you've never
seen twenty two thousand dollars in your
life
all right
your mom has supported you forever but
y'all are this thing you're not talking
anymore
your boys wanna go out and party
you've never seen this kind of money you
got choices to make now where are you
going to put that cash you're going to
support the mom that's not talking to
you but she's been natural you want to
go to the boys and party you're going to
split it evenly you're going to save it
in your account you have to start making
harder choices a man comes up to you and
smacks you in your face why did he do it
because he doesn't like arab folks
okay now you have choices tonight how
are you going to respond you're going to
[ __ ] out you're going to catch him
slipping when he's by himself are you
going to find him in front of everybody
and potentially take an l and risk it
all
you got choices to make
right and when you're faced with these
choices that's when your character
starts to develop because you're
literally building your story as you go
as you make these choices who you become
becomes conquer concretized i don't
think that's a word
cemented we'll just go with that
oh you just decided to not use concrete
but cement
you already know bro your choices become
asphalt
i'm out of this i mean i i'm concretized
i don't think there's a word doesn't
matter they got
how many times do i
invent words yeah that's true
come on now just stay with your chest
okay congrats
[Music]
so you know when we when we sit and we
talk about this stuff it's like
understand that's my that's my advice to
young people in general like what do i
do i feel lost you're always going to
feel lost because you don't know who you
are how do you want to guide yourself
when you don't even know the direction
you want to go in or where you're trying
to get to of course you're going to feel
lost i was feeling lost at that age too
i felt lost probably until i was 25 you
know and some people feel lost you're
lucky
go ahead
lucky right geez man 25 yeah man i was
lost till i was maybe
33. there you go
so when you guys are dealing with this
stuff and you're having to make these
difficult choices just know
that the only way for you to be i'm good
with who i am i know me i know what i
like i know a lot of stuff i don't like
maybe i'll still learn a few things here
and there but i got a good idea
okay
but i only know that because i tested my
character in difficult situations and i
want to see from the values that i claim
to love stood the test of that difficult
situation was i going to compromise and
if i was
what does that mean about my values
those are conversations you start having
with yourself right
i know i'll never steal
i've never stolen i've been offered
opportunities great opportunities to
make a lot of money via stealing
but instead of going in for that
temptation i resisted even though it was
right in front of my force easy could
have gotten away with it
that's how i knew all right that value
set in stone i'm not going to do wrong
by people just because it benefits me do
you understand those kind of situations
i'm talking about so if you're a young
person out there go seek out adversity
whether it's a new job new location
living out on your own all right doing
things that scare you those will define
you as a human being i think that's the
kind of gist of it and then with that
naturally you'll be able to get
comfortable around the opposite sex
that's it yeah you know
let me let me rephrase that last part
it's not gonna get comfortable with the
opposite sex you'll have something to
present to the opposite sex after that
you got to have integrity enough to say
this who i am like me or don't but this
is what i'm about
all right
because you're just you you know who you
are you present that to the
okay so anyways that was kind of just
like the theory i had yeah anything you
want to say no it makes sense
[Music]
foreign